allez c'est parti pour l'éjaculation
précoce comment ça marche il peut y
avoir des causes physiques comme un
pénis trop sensible par exemple sensible
ça peut aussi être la conséquence d'un
problème comme une inflammation de la
prostate par exemple dans l'immense
majorité des cas la cause elle est
psychologique et émotionnelle on peut
pas dire que ce soit une maladie parce
que à la base physiologiquement on est
comme les autres animaux on est
programmé pour éjaculer le plus vite
possible ah oui parce que pendant qu'on
est occupé à faire notre petit business
là on est quand même particulièrement
vulnérable et du coup on risque de se
faire bouffer par un prédateur bah oui
parce que les hormones du stress comme
l'adrénaline par exemple au départ le
rôle c'était de nous mettre en condition
pour faire face à un danger donc
aujourd'hui encore si pour une raison ou
pour une autre on se met la pression
pendant un coït BIM montée d'hormones du
stress notre corps il pense qu'on va se
faire grailler et il nous dit mais tu
vas combattre personne avec ton machin
là et du coup hop
le sperme voilà donc en réalité le
principal problème c'est une difficulté
voire une incapacité à contrôler son
excitation